here's some their best-selling author
Brad Meltzer is known for crafting
fictional thrillers now he's focusing on
a real-life mystery his new book is
called the first conspiracy the secret
plot to kill that general that's George
Washington kill George Washington it
details an effort to undermine the
American Revolution just before the
signing of the Declaration of
Independence and with British troops
about to invade New York City the plot
connects counterfeiters leading New York
politicians and even the future
president's own bodyguards Brad Meltzer
is here first on CBS this morning good
morning good to see you how did you find
this story yeah you know I found this
story in the place where all the best
stories are found which is in the
footnotes and when I saw it I was like
is this true a plot to kill George
Washington that no one knows about and
it was true this is Joseph Ellis who's
the Pulitzer prize-winning biographer
yeah I went to him and I said I said you
know that this really happened and it
really happened when it happened George
Washington rounded up those responsible
he took one of the main conspirators and
he hung him in front of 20,000 people
the largest public execution at that
point in North American history he
brought the hammer down was like I'm
George Washington he was mad I'm gonna
be on the money one day right why did
this story go secret when fake stories
about Washington like cutting down the
cherry tree which is apocryphal were
were nevertheless ones that lived on and
listen what the hanging happened on June
28 1776 guess what was happening anymore
all Declaration of Independence yeah I
mean the British are literally there and
this gets lost with but it's the most
amazing moment because George Washington
that time had his own private bodyguards
and he asked his regiments for the four
best men that they could find one of the
best of the best and these were the men
who turned on him they were called The
Life Guards because they guarded George
Washington's life and I don't care how
strong you are when your inner circle
turns on yeah it is yeah yeah it hurt
his feelings you even write that he
never talked about how he felt and how
he found out about it but you said it
must have really hurt his soul yeah
because listen this is the closest your
nearest and dearest right his personal
life guards are the ones who turn on him
and the housekeeper you said might have
been it right they that's an excuse Livy
in his house and she disappears in the
middle of the night and it truly becomes
a mystery but what George Washington
does is he immediately launches a secret
committee to figure out what's happening
he calls it the greatest name of all the
Committee on conspiracies and with John
Jay leading the charge and this is you
know John Jay is the fourth Supreme
Court justice he puts into motion
interrogations kicking in doors and to
this day we all think of the CIA the
precursor B in the OSS it's actually
this moment to this day and Secret
Service headquarters in in CIA
headquarters in Langley Virginia there's
a room dedicated to John Jay the father
of counterintelligence so it's not just
the secret plot to kill George
Washington what you see in the book is
you really see the birth of the
counterintelligence movement in the
United why did they want to kill him
they listened he was the man in charge
and what and what I love about it is you
get to see George Washington's character
yeah you know when when George
Washington is I've seen in the Battle of
Brooklyn and he's totally pinned against
the wall he should give up at that
moment and instead he plans a daring
escape and what he does is he can
commandeer as all the boats on the East
River but here's the key moment he won't
get in the boats until all his men get
in first yeah and his men see what he's
doing he's risking his life for them and
so again what you see is not just the
plot against George Washington the depth
of his character and we need that in our
leaders today we need to see you know
George Washington brought this country
together their wonder United States he
brought it together by putting his arms
around an insane to his own regiments
don't fight with each other don't argue
each other we need to be on the same
team that's what we are today
all right build the presidency on that
character thank you Brad Meltzer the
first conspiracy the secret plot to kill
George Washington is available today